- Do you see anything wrong
with what your son did?
- So the Q-Shaman's mom
was apparently defending him on 60 Minutes
and it's a train wreck, let's watch.
- What do you mean by wrong, like, wrong?
- Well, by wrong, it means illegal.
- [Interviewer] Do you
see the gravity of it?
- I feel the gravity of it
because my son is in, he's
where he is right now.
- He's in jail waiting to be prosecuted
for all the crimes that he committed.
That's where he is.
- If he could take it back, he would.
- 'Cause it was illegal.
- He walked through open doors.
- He walked through open doors
that he wasn't allowed to walk through.
- My son was there,
but he wasn't a part
of the bad part of it.
- Right.
That's not a thing that is not
a legally defensible thing.
I don't think it's right
that it was one fraudulently.
Yeah, well that has nothing to do with
whether your son committed
multiple felonies.
Spoiler alert, he did.
So subscribe or I'll see you in court.